[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
[Applaus]
Russland Russland skandieren sie zum
Schluss unter den Kronleuchtern des
Kreml am Ende einer Zeremonie die in die
Geschichtsbücher eingehen wird als
folgenreicher und eklatanter Bruch des
Völkerrechts
guten Abend ihnen allen russlands
Präsident feiert den Anschluss der
besetzten Gebiete in der Ukraine an sein
Land in einer Mischung aus hasserfüllter
Wutrede und großmachtsfantasien und
beginnt damit wie die NATO sagt die
ernteste Eskalation seit Beginn des
Krieges wir berichten ausführlich in
dieser Sendung über die Reaktionen und
folgen aber erst der Tag in Moskau von
Sebastian ehm
es ist Wladimir Putins zweite Rede an
diesem Tag vor seinen Anhängern auf dem
Roten Platz will er keinen Zweifel
lassen das ist ein Tag des Triumphs
wir sind stärker geworden weil wir
vereint sind und weil die Wahrheit auf
unserer Seite ist und Wahrheit heißt
macht der Sieg wird unser sein
der Jubel die Kulisse die Wortwahl alles
ist fein säuberlich inszeniert rund um
den Roten Platz sind die meisten zum
Feiern hier
wir sind sehr glücklich hier zu sein um
das alles zu sehen gemeinsam mit ganz
Russland
nur einzelne Stimmen sehen das anders
das ist der dramatischste Moment seit
in Russland wurde ein faschistisches
Regime gebildet ich würde sagen das ist
der Abschaum des Faschismus
vier Stunden vorher schafft Putin Fakten
er setzt seine Unterschrift unter die
anschlussurkunde der teilweise von
Russland besetzten Gebiete doniewsk
luhansk saporicia und herson sie sollen
jetzt Teil von Russland werden in der
Lesart des Kreml heißt das vor allem das
Angriffe auf diese Gebiete als Angriffe
auf Russland gewertet werden
wir werden unser Land mit all unseren
Kräften und Mitteln verteidigen wir
werden alles tun um das Leben unserer
Leute zu retten das ist die großartige
befreiende Rolle unserer Nation
im prachtvollen Georg Saal gibt sich
Wladimir Putin vor der versammelten
politischen Elite Moskaus als Macher der
Russland zu alter Stärke zurückführt die
Botschaft die er heute vor allem ins
eigene Land senden will ist ich habe
alles im Griff und wir werden siegen das
überhaupt gekämpft wird nicht seine
Schuld doch Russland sei bereit zu
verhandeln zu seinen Bedingungen
wir rufen das kiewa Regime auf alle
Kämpfe zu beenden diesen Krieg den sie
2014 begonnen haben sie sollen an den
Verhandlungstisch zurückkommen wir sind
bereit das haben wir immer wieder betont
aber wir werden die Entscheidung der
Menschen in luhansk donieck saporiscia
und herson nicht diskutieren sie haben
sich entschieden und Russland wird sie
nicht im Stich lassen
das ist die Welt wie Vladimir Putin sie
sieht und seinem Volk verkaufen will er
hofft damit die Russen wieder hinter
sich zu versammeln
[Musik]
und so sieht das neue Reich aus wie es
sich der Machthaber im Kreml vorstellt
türkis Russland in orange die neu
annektierten Regionen insgesamt etwa so
groß wie Bayern und Baden-Württemberg
zusammen bestehend aus ukrainischen
Gebieten die gar nicht mal komplett
unter der Kontrolle der russischen
Besatzer sind selbst der kremlsprecher
sagt heute dass er die Grenzen von zwei
der vier neuen Regionen noch klären
müsse während die russische Armee durch
vorrückende Einheiten der Ukraine weiter
unter Druck gerät und die New York Times
veröffentlicht Mitschnitte von
Telefonaten die russische Besatzung
Soldaten in der Ukraine führten mit
ihren Familien Eltern Freunden zu Hause
die Zeitung sagt sie hat die Echtheit
verifiziert es ergibt sich das Bild
einer Armee in desolatem Zustand
da wissen junge Männer nicht wofür sie
kämpfen sollen Soldaten verlieren den
Glauben an die die Sie in diesen Krieg
geschickt haben
die Reaktion der Menschen die all das
was Russlands präsidenta heute verkündet
zuallererst betrifft zeigt jetzt Tor
Gebote in seiner Reportage er ist im
Nordosten der Ukraine
eine kleine Stadt östlich von rakev die
Nachbarregion Don jetzt wurde heute von
den Russen annektiert erst vor wenigen
Tagen wurden die letzten russischen
Soldaten aus kobians zurückgedrängt
sicher ist es hier aber noch lang nicht
die Frontlinie ist nur 5 km entfernt
[Musik]
es gibt ein großes Problem und das ist
der Fluss
das ist aber das einzige Problem
ansonsten geht es gut voran
Priorität hat die Rettung der Menschen
und danach versuchen wir auch so viele
Gebäude wie möglich zu retten aber noch
die Rettung der Menschen hat absoluten
Vorrang
möglichst verlassen und dann können wir
weitermachen
und viele Menschen verlassen die Stadt
die jungen gehen die älteren bleiben
meist zurück wollen die Heimat nicht
verlassen diese Brücke über den Fluss
oskiel teilt kubiansk in zwei Teile die
Farben Russlands haben die Besatzer aufs
Geländer gesprüht Holländer hat es auf
die sichere Seite geschafft sie steht
noch immer völlig unter Schock
sehr furchtbar wir haben bis zuletzt
ausgehalten dann haben sie uns mit
Raketen beschossen viele sind vor
unseren Augen gestorben deswegen haben
wir entschieden nach haarkiff zu fliehen
wie es weitergeht weiß ich nicht dann
fragen wir nach der Annexion und was sie
davon hält
nein nein das ist unser Land unsere
Ukraine nein es ist alles sehr furchtbar
aber ich vertraue darauf dass es unsere
Ukraine bleibt Ukraine
Alexey rette noch ein paar Bücher aus
der Bibliothek er will sie im
Krankenhaus vorbeibringen wo verletzte
Soldaten liegen seine Antwort auf die
Frage nach der Annektion hören wir in
den letzten Tagen immer wieder in der
Ostukraine oh
Putin soll zur Hölle fahren zusammen mit
seinem ganzen Gefolge das sage ich von
ganzem Herzen und im Namen meiner
Freunde er wird es nicht schaffen
viele aber die wir hier treffen Wissen
tatsächlich gar nichts von einem Schein
Referendum oder eine Annektion
wochenlang waren sie von der Außenwelt
abgeschnitten hatten keinen Zugang zu
Nachrichten
wir hatten kein Internet wir wohnten wie
in einem Vakuum wenn wir Licht gehabt
hätten wären wir gar nicht weggegangen
bei uns gab es aber keine Möglichkeit
irgendwelche Informationen zu kriegen
doch aus russischer Sicht wurden heute
Fakten geschaffen neue Grenzen gezogen
Grenzen die der Rest der Welt nicht
akzeptiert mit Gewalt will sich Moskau
Teile der Ukraine einverleiben die
Ukraine wird dabei allerdings nicht
tatenlos zusehen
was für ein Bild da am Ende des Beitrags
bringen wir unsere Korrespondenten mit
dazu in der Ukraine und in Russland
zunächst in die Ukraine Torge guten
Abend wie hat man sich denn das jetzt
vor Ort vorzustellen wo ja der
Frontverlauf tatsächlich auch wieder in
Bewegung ist was ändert sich denn
konkret mit dieser Annexion
also aus ukrainischer Sicht ändert sich
eigentlich gar nichts das bleibt dabei
was Präsident selenske gesagt hat man
wird weiter versuchen die besetzten
Gebiete zurück zur erobern und die
Annexion das Spiel für ihn keine Rolle
das verändert die Ziele nicht was ich
verändert ist das Tempo auf das gedrückt
wird also was wir hier beobachten ist
dass man versucht möglichst viele
Gebiete
zurückzuerobern solange es der
russischen Seite nicht gelingt oder
nicht im ausreichenden Maße gelingt neue
Soldaten und Waffen an die Frontlinie zu
bringen durch die teilmobilisierung und
für die Zivilbevölkerung wie sieht es da
aus wir haben vor allen Dingen in der
Region zur politischer vor einigen Tagen
sehen können das immer mehr Menschen
versuchen die Gebiete zu verlassen die
Menschen haben einfach Angst vor einer
weiteren Eskalation des Konflikts und
bei den Männern ist es so dass da die
Angst durchaus besteht in den
Kriegsdienst Zwangs eingezogen zu werden
und in dem Fall würde das bedeuten dass
Ukrainer auf Ukrainer schießen
vielen Dank weiter nach Moskau zu
Christian sem Christian es scheint ja
heute einem altbekannten man muss
vielleicht auch sagen berüchtigten
Fahrplan zu folgen das Ganze vor acht
Jahren nach der Annexion der Krim waren
Putins Beliebtheitswerte nach oben
gegangen ist das heute wieder zu
erwarten oder wie kommt dieser Tag bei
den Russinnen und Russen an
es gibt sogar eine aktuelle
Meinungsumfrage von heute vom
levadazentrum und demnach liegen die
Zustimmungswerte von Wladimir Putin bei
den Russen Russen bei 80 Prozent aber
ich finde diese Zahlen die sind immer
mit großer Vorsicht zu genießen man muss
sich klar machen dass Meinungsumfragen
in einem
totalitären System natürlich ja
schwierig zu betrachten sind du hast die
Krim angesprochen 2014 ich finde das war
eine andere Zeit und die Krim hat auch
für Russland eine ganz andere
symbolische Bedeutung im Moment bedrückt
jedoch viele Familien und hat auch Panik
ausgelöst in den letzten Tagen seit
Verkündung der teilmobilisierung dass
die Menschen sich Fragen wird mein Vater
mein Bruder mein Onkel ich selbst
vielleicht werde ich in diesen Konflikt
mit reingezogen und muss vielleicht an
die Front ich glaube diese Frage bewegt
die Menschen im Moment sehr viel mehr
als das Putin heute vier ukrainische
Gebiete der Russischen Föderation
angeschlossen hat
ganz herzlichen Dank an unsere
Korrespondenten den gesamten Nachmittag
über Jagd heute eine Eilmeldung die
nächste ein Land nach dem anderen
verurteilt Wladimir Putin und das
russische Vorgehen von der Schweiz bis
nach Schweden die Annexion werde man
nicht anerkennen heißt es da immer
wieder der Ukraine selbst reichen solche
Worte nicht sie will jetzt im
Schnellverfahren Teil der NATO werden
Gunnar Krüger
Provokation ruft nach Reaktion in
Brüssel Berlin und Washington
dieser landraupe ist
illegal und ungerechtfertigt an der
Rechtslage hat sich nichts verändert an
der Realität hat sich nichts verändert
dieses Geschwätz über Atomwaffen ist der
Gipfel der Verantwortungslosigkeit
erst die mutmaßliche Sabotage an
Pipelines nun die mutwillige Verletzung
von Völkerrecht Putin setzt die Agenda
der besten läuft hinterher diesen
Eindruck will Jens Stoltenberg vermeiden
Frage des ZDF soll die Ukraine angreifen
was Putin nach seiner Doktrin auch
atomar verteidigen dürfte dazu müssen
darum unterstützen wir sie damit sie
sich verteidigen und weiter ihre Gebiete
zurückerobern und die deutsche
Außenministerin sagt
verteidigen wir haben die Äußerungen von
dem russischen Präsidenten vom ersten
Tag dieses Krieges ernst genommen aber
wir haben uns davon zugleich nicht
einschüchtern lassen
nuklearer Erpressung gibt die NATO nicht
nach aber auch nicht diesen Wunsch der
Ukraine
wir vertrauen wir helfen wir schützen
einander das ist eine Allianz de facto
heute stellt die Ukraine auch formal
ihren Aufnahmeantrag
die Antwort des größten NATO-Verbündeten
wir sind für die offene Tür der NATO
dafür gibt es einen Prozess und dem
müssen Länder weiter folgen
die Ukraine wartet also weiter sie
kämpft weiter die Nato will weiter nicht
Kriegspartei sein die Annexion hat alles
verändert und doch nichts
der Militärexperte und
Politikwissenschaftler Carlo Masala von
der Universität der Bundeswehr ist bei
uns Herr Professor willkommen zurück im
heute schon argonat schönen guten Abend
mit dem heutigen Tag beansprucht das
Russland von Vladimir Putin eine neue
Westgrenze die ist jetzt ja gar nicht
wirklich komplett kontrolliert und die
völkerrechtlich auch nicht anerkannt ist
inwieweit ändert das denn die Gesamtlage
Objektiv ändert das die Gesamtlage
überhaupt nicht weil wie sie ja gerade
gesagt haben es ist sozusagen eine
illegale Annexion von ukrainischen
Gebiet in die Russische Föderation aber
aus der russischen Logik heraus wird das
nun in den Teilen die Russland
kontrolliert aber auch in den Teilen die
die Ukraine kontrolliert weil sie zu
Russland jetzt aus russischer
Perspektive gehören ein Angriff auf das
Territorium der Russischen Föderation
und Putin hat das ja heute auch schon
gesagt dass er diesen Angriff auf das
Territorium der Russischen Föderation
mit allen Mitteln verteidigen wird also
es ist aus russischer Perspektive jetzt
keine militärische spezialoperation in
der Kabine mehr sondern ein Angriff auf
russisches Territorium Putin ging ja
sogar noch so ein Schritt weiter und hat
quasi von einem Kampf um die Existenz
Russlands gesprochen welche Schlüsse
lassen sich denn aus all dem jetzt
ziehen wie er weiter vorgehen wird in
Zukunft
ich glaube wir werden keine große
Veränderung sehen in der Art und Weise
wie Putin weiter vorgehen wird ich fand
es interessant dass der Keimen Sprecher
pescov vorher bei einer Pressekonferenz
noch mal darauf hingewiesen hat dass
sozusagen es unverantwortlich sei ich
paraphrasiere das jetzt mal wenn man
jetzt von einer atomaren Eskalation
sprechen würde und dass die russische
Militärdoktrin eindeutig sei
Nuklearwaffen würden nur dann eingesetzt
werden wenn es um die Existenz des
russischen Staates gehen würde das ist
alles jetzt so ein bisschen nach dieser
Rede am 22.09 wo Putin noch mal sehr
deutlich mit Nuklearwaffen gedroht hat
klingt das jetzt ein bisschen
verhaltener ohne dass man allerdings
irgendeine Option vom Tisch genommen hat
ja denn auch wenn er wie sie gerade
gesagt haben heute sagt auf Attacken mit
allen zur Verfügung stehenden Mitteln zu
reagieren da fragen sich ja dann doch
immer sehr viele beinhaltet das auch
einen Atomschlag ist denn der mit dem
heutigen Tag aus ihrer Sicht
wahrscheinlicher geworden
nein ich glaube die Gefahr sozusagen des
nuklearen Einsatzes seitens der
Russischen Föderation ist genau die
gleiche die wir haben seit im Prinzip im
ersten Tag des Krieges es ist ein Krieg
der von einer nuklear macht geführt wird
wonuklearwaffen eine Rolle spielen in in
deren Strategie das darf man nicht aus
dem Auge verlieren aber ich glaube nicht
dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines
Einsatzes von Nuklearwaffen jetzt durch
diese Rede und durch diese Handlung der
Annexion signifikant gestiegen ist
gucken wir mal auf auf uns hier im
Westen heute aus dem Westen einhellige
Verurteilung wir werden das niemals
anerkennen sagen eigentlich alle Staaten
eine nach dem anderen wie muss denn der
Westen jetzt reagieren reichen da Worte
so wie heute oder oder mit Taten
wir haben letzten Endes die gleiche
Situation die wir auch vor zwei oder
drei Wochen hatten also zum einen gilt
es die Russische Föderation
abzuschrecken im Sinne von wenn sie
Nuklearwaffen einsetzen würde würde der
Preis für sie enorm steigen also
amerikanische spreche katastrophale
Konsequenzen für die Russische
Föderation dass der zweite Punkt ist wir
müssen weiterhin die Ukraine
unterstützen bei ihren Versuch sozusagen
die durch Russen besetzte Gebiete wieder
zurückzubekommen und da sind wir wieder
bei der leidigen Diskussion über
Schützenpanzer und Kampfpanzer die wir
seit Monaten führen aber das ist unter
anderem nicht alleine nicht aber unter
anderem das was die ukrainische Armee
jetzt vor Ort brauchen würde die
Einordnung von Carlo Masala von der
Universität der Bundeswehr Prof vielen
Dank dafür ich danke Ihnen
und teilst du bleibst hier bei den
Nachrichten noch in der Ukraine ja die
ukrainische Armee hat laut Präsident
silensky weitere Erfolge in der Region
dann jetzt erzielt und es sollte Ukraine
gelungen sein russische Einheiten in der
strategisch wichtigen Stadt Liman
einzukesseln bei einem Raketenangriff in
der Stadt saporicia auf einen zivilen
Autokonvoi sind heute 30 Menschen
getötet worden weitere 88 Menschen
wurden verletzt der Konvoi wartete um
Angehörige aus den von russischen
Truppen besetzten Gebieten abzuholen und
Hilfe zu bringen
russland hat im UN-Sicherheitsrat mit
einem Veto die Verabschiedung einer
Resolution verhindert mit der die
Annexion von ukrainischen Gebieten als
Völkerrechtsbruch verurteilt werden
sollte zehn Länder stimmten in New York
für das von den USA und Albanien
vorgeschlagene Dokument darin wird
Russland zum sofortigen Rückzug aus der
Ukraine aufgefordert bei der Abstimmung
haben sich China Indien Brasilien und
Gabun enthalten
der deutsche Arbeitsmarkt zeigt sich
trotz der krisenden Wirtschaft weiterhin
robust und dank der üblichen
herbstbelegung ist die Zahl der
Arbeitslosen zurückgegangen im September
waren zwei Millionen
486.000 Menschen ohne Arbeit
62.000 weniger als im August die Quote
liegt bei 5,4 Prozent im Vergleich zum
Vorjahresmonat ist die Zahl der
Arbeitslosen um 21.000 gestiegen was die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit auch mit der
Erfassung der ukrainischen Flüchtlinge
erklärt
der gesetzliche Mindestlohn steigt
morgen zum ersten Oktober von 10,45 auf
12 Euro pro Stunde Arbeitsminister
halzufolge sollen von der Anhebung über
6 Millionen Beschäftigte profitieren und
gleichzeitig werden die Verdienstgrenzen
für Minijobs von 450 auf 520 Euro
angehoben zu corona-pandemie deutschland
stehe am Beginn einer herbst- und
winterwelle so Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach obwohl die Fallzahlen steigen
sei eine Zunahme schwerer Verläufe nicht
erkennbar Deutschlands sehr besser
vorbereitet als vergangenen Herbst
Lauterbach appellierte jedoch an die
Bundesländer ihren Spielraum zur
Verschärfung von Maßnahmen zu nutzen
wenn nötig
so sieht einer der stärksten Stürme aus
der jemals das Festland der USA erreicht
hat es war möglicherweise der tödlichste
und er traf ein Paradies Floridas
Golfküste Traumwelt von Touristen und
winterflüchtlingen jetzt verwüstet es
wird Monate dauern bis die Schäden auch
nur erfasst sind über ihn werden wir
noch jahrzehntelang sprechen sagt die
us-katastrophenschutzbehörde Ulrike
rödle berichtet
das Schlimmste für die Menschen ist das
viele Wasser in einigen Gegenden steht
es noch immer Mieter hoch noch sollen
tausende in ihren Häusern eingeschlossen
sein vermutet der Katastrophenschutz
hier in Furth Myers traf Hurricane vor
drei Tagen an Land
ich bin so lange geblieben bis es nicht
mehr ging ich hatte Angst um mein Leben
ich habe gesehen wie mein Haus
buchstäblich im Wasser versank vor
meinen Augen und alles was drin war ist
weg
ein Floridas Küste haben Wind und Wasser
komplette Ortschaften zerstört Häuser
und Straßen weggerissen von mindestens
21 Toten sprechen die Behörden doch sie
glauben dass es noch viel mehr werden
in Fort Myers wohnte auch Wilma Jean sie
ist zurückgekommen um zu sehen was von
ihrem Haus übrig geblieben ist
hier haben wir vorgefunden ich habe
dieses Haus erst vor sechs Monaten
gekauft von meinem Ersparten zum Glück
habe ich eine Familie die mir hilft das
zu retten was noch zu retten ist
die Regierung in Washington verspricht
noch mehr Hilfe Präsident beiden wendet
sich am Abend an die Bevölkerung
Floridas
viele Häuser sind zerstört es wird
Monate bis Jahre dauern alles aufzubauen
unser Herz ist bei all dem deren
Existenz durch den Sturm zerstört wurde
ich möchte den Menschen in Florida sagen
dass wir an ihrer Seite sind und dass
wir alles tun werden um zu helfen
die amerikanische Küstenwache hat
inzwischen ihre Teams in Florida weiter
verstärkt und hofft noch mehr Menschen
aus der Luft zu retten am späten
Nachmittag wendet sich der
Katastrophenschutz an die Menschen
dieses Mal ins South Carolina
wir sehen schon die ersten Auswirkungen
von Hurricane South Carolina und in
Georgia es ist jetzt an der Zeit dem
Evakuierungsplan der behördenfolge zu
leisten bitte verfolgen sie auch den
Wetterbericht und hören Sie auf die
Anweisungen von lokalen Behörden
Hurrikan Ian ist angekommen in South
Carolina er ist nun ein Hurrikan der
Kategorie 1 doch die Angst der Menschen
vor den Fluten ist groß auch hier noch
ist die Gefahr nicht vorbei
und Hans guckt jetzt hier auf die Preise
ja nach dem gestern die Bundesregierung
Ihr Paket gegen die hohen Energiepreise
angekündigt hat gab es heute weitere
Schritte zur Entlastung der Bundestag
beschloss die Mehrwertsteuer auf Gas und
Fernwärme von 19 auf 7% zu senken und
die EU Energieminister haben eine
Kompromiss erzielt der beim Strompreis
Entlastung schaffen soll Frank Bethmann
mit welchem Konzept gehen die
Energieminister daran ja nach
wochenlangen Diskussionen gab es heute
eine Einigung der Getroffene Beschluss
zwingt die Energieunternehmen künftig
dazu einen Teil ihrer krisengewinne an
den Staat abzugeben der derzeit sehr
hohe Gewinn der Stromerzeuger wird
begrenzt auf welche Höhe kann flexibel
von den Mitgliedsländern angepasst
werden als Richtwert gelten 180 Euro pro
Megawattstunde etwa die Hälfte des
derzeitigen Preises alles darüber hinaus
soll vom Staat abgeschöpft werden um
Haushalte und Firmen zu entlasten auch
Gas und Ölkonzerne gut ein Drittel ihrer
diesjährigen übergewinne abgeben zudem
einigten sich die Staaten darauf
schlicht weniger Strom zu verbrauchen
insgesamt zehn Prozent wie sie das
machen bleibt unkonkret sehr viel
konkreter ist da schon dass der
September kein guter Monat für Aktien
war der DAX gibt in den letzten vier
Wochen über fünfeinhalb Prozent nach
traditionell ist der September der
schwächste Börsenmonat im Jahr und es
gab zuletzt ja nun auch wirklich kaum
gute Gründe für steigende Kurse Frank
Bethmann vielen Dank
in der Fußball-Bundesliga hat der FC
Bayern München nach vier sieglosen
Spielen wieder gewonnen 4:0 endete das
Heimspiel gegen Bayer Leverkusen
im Sommer waren im deutsch-polnischen
Grenzfluss oder massenhaft Fische
gestorben heute hat das
Bundesumweltministerium einen
Expertenbericht über die Ursachen des
Fischsterbens veröffentlicht demnach hat
ein überhöhter Salzgehalt zur
Massenvermehrung einer giftigen
brackwasseralge geführt diese gilt als
Ursache des Fischsterbens der niedrige
Wasserstand und die hohe
Wassertemperatur im Sommer haben die
Konzentration der Alge noch erhöht die
Ursache für den hohen Salzgehalt ist
weiterhin unklar
ja und das war dieser ereignisreiche
Freitag im heute-journal jetzt gleich
weiter mit dem brandneuen Politbarometer
und Matthias vornhof tschüss
guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer
überfallen okkupieren annektieren
Vladimir Putins brutales Vorgehen gegen
die Ukraine offenbart was er vom Prinzip
des Völkerrechts hält nichts
während der kremme des Pot seine
pseudo-referenten über den Anschluss an
Russland mit vorgehaltenen Waffen
abhalten ließ erobert die ukrainische
Armee Gebiete zurück wohl auch deshalb
glauben gut 40% der Befragten dass die
Ukraine den Krieg gegen Russland
gewinnen wird deutlich mehr als im
August
bei der Frage ob Deutschland der Ukraine
Kampfpanzer liefern soll sind die
Deutschen gespalten
47% sind dafür 43 dagegen mehrheitlich
dafür sind die Anhänger der
ampelparteien und die der Union am
höchsten ist die Zustimmung bei den
Anhängern der Grünen am geringsten bei
denen der AFD
der russische Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine geht in den achten Monat während
zwei Flugstunden entfernt gekämpft und
gestorben wird setzt Putin auf
Zermürbung bei uns eine seiner Waffen
gegen den Westen ausbleibendes Gas die
deutschen bleiben bisher aber standhaft
in ihrer Solidarität mit der Ukraine
74% meinen dass wir das angegriffene
Land weiter unterstützen sollten auch
wenn das mit höheren Energiepreisen bei
uns verbunden ist im August sagten das
71 Prozent im Juli 70 jeder fünfte war
und ist dagegen die Ukraine weiterhin zu
unterstützen wenn das höhere
Energiepreise bedeutet
die konstant hohen Werte sind umso
bemerkenswerter als die höheren Kosten
jetzt bei der Mehrheit der Deutschen
deutlich spürbar sind
für 57% sind die stark gestiegenen
Preise ein großes Problem für 42 Prozent
nicht im Juli war es noch andersrum 40
Prozent sagten da dass in die höheren
Kosten große Probleme bereiten die
Mehrheit aber spürte das vor zwei
Monaten nicht in diesem Umfang
jetzt will die Bundesregierung die Gas-
und Strompreise Deckeln kreditfinanziert
mit 200 Milliarden Euro Details sind
noch offen mit diesem Doppel Wumms wie
der Kanzler die Hilfsaktion nennt will
die Koalition wieder in die Offensive
kommen nach dem wochenlangen Streit um
die gasumlage die jetzt entfällt
die Unzufriedenheit mit der Ampel ist
derzeit so groß wie nie
knapp jeder Zweite meint dass die
Bundesregierung ihre Arbeit eher gut
macht 44 Prozent finden sie arbeitet
schlecht im März kurz nach Ausbruch des
Krieges waren 75% der Befragten mit der
Arbeit der Ampel zufrieden nur etwa
jeder fünfte nicht
wie wirkt sich diese Stimmung auf
unserer Sonntagsfrage aus wenn am
nächsten Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre
käme die SPD auf 18 Prozent minus 1
cdu/cso 27 ebenfalls einen Punkt runter
auch die Grünen -1
22%. die FDP 7 die AFD 14 bei der etwas
stärker die Linke unverändert 5%
die Ampel hätte damit nur noch eine
hauchdünne Mehrheit als einziges
Zweierbündnis würde es für Schwarz-Grün
reichen
schauen wir auf unsere Top Ten also die
Bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker nach
Sympathie und Leistung auf der Skala von
+5 bis -5 geht es für fast alle abwärts
Alice Weidel ist Schlusslicht -2,8
schlechter
vorletzte Sahra Wagenknecht minus 1,3
stark verschlechtert Friedrich Merz -0,3
auch mit Verlusten Markus Söder minus
0,2 schlechter davor Christian Lindner
-0,1 Karl Lauterbach -0,1 etwas
schlechter Robert Habeck 0,4 erneut
deutliche Verluste auf dem dritten Platz
Olaf Scholz 0,5
zweite Anna-Lena baerbock 0,5 schlechter
und ganz vorne weil die anderen so
schwächeln Cem Özdemir 0,5 ebenfalls mit
Verlusten
am Montag wird Deutschland 32 Jahre
vereint sein haben die beiden deutschen
Staaten zueinander gefunden da gehen die
Ansichten in Ost und West auseinander
was überwiegt zwischen West und
Ostdeutschland die Gemeinsamkeiten oder
die Unterschiede für die Befragten im
Westen für 57 Prozent die
Gemeinsamkeiten für 36 Prozent die
Unterschiede ziemlich genau andersrum
die Stimmung im Osten hier sagen 38
Prozent das ist mehr gemeinsames gibt 57
Prozent aber spüren deutlicher die
Unterschiede
fast alle deutschen nämlich 92 Prozent
finden dass die Wiedervereinigung
richtig war hier gibt es kaum
Unterschiede zwischen West und Ost es
gibt also schon einen Grund zum Feiern
am dritten Oktober
das war unser Bericht über die Stimmung
im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF textab Seite 165 in
der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF heute.de
wie die repräsentativen Umfragen der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen zustande kommen
Informationen zur Methodik und zu den
Qualitätsstandards finden Sie unter
politbarometer.zdf.de
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse das
nächste Politbarometer gibt es dann am
21 Oktober hier folgt jetzt das Wetter
danach geht es weiter mit der heute show
viel Spaß dabei und einen schönen Abend
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
und was morgen beim Wetter passiert ist
noch ziemlich klar dieses stürmische
tiefweil Burger bringt uns Regen der uns
vom West nach Ost überquert am Sonntag
dann aber kommt eine kleine
tiefdruckwelle und wie genau die ziehen
wird ist noch nicht ganz klar sieht sie
eher über die Mitte Deutschlands oder
eher über den Süden beschäftigen uns
erstmal mit der Nacht denn da zieht
Regen heran und der erreicht bis zum
frühen Morgen Fehmarn und das Breisgau
im Ostens ist dagegen zum Teil noch klar
da sinken die Temperaturen auf sechs bis
zwei Grad und der den Regenwolken im
Westen bleibt es bei 11 bis 7 Grad
milder und morgen zieht der Regen weiter
ostwärts schon mittags erreichte die
oder die nice und das Berchtesgadener
Land dahinter lockern die Wolken auch
mal auf es gibt kräftige Regenschauer
zum Teil auch Gewitter sie müssen sich
auf stürmische Böden einstellen vor
allen Dingen über den
mittelgebirgsgipfel wenn es länger
regnet dann bleibt es auch recht kühl
mit frischen 11 bis 14 oder 15 Grad 16
oder 17 Grad sind es aber bereits hier
zwischen der Weser und dem Niederrhein
am Sonntag uns dann kräftig schütten
entweder in Süddeutschland oder auch
etwas weiter in der Mitte ab Montag
setzt sich dann dieses Hoch durch das
bedeutet Sonnenschein und Nebel oder
Hochnebel dann steigen die Temperaturen
am Dienstag vielleicht sogar bis 20 Grad
das ist schon eine ganze Menge aber noch
nicht das was wir in China erwarten da
wird es nämlich für Anfang Oktober am
Montag exorbitant warm mehr als 40 Grad
gab es da bisher noch nie guten Abend